Today, we'll talk about another knowledge representation called scripts.
Scripts allow us to make sense of discourses and stories and
scenes. Scripts are the culmination of of frames and understanding and
common sense reasoning these last few lessons. We'll take what we learned about
frames and understanding and common sense reasoning to build superior scripts.
We'll start by defining scripts, then we'll talk about the form and
the content of scripts. Then we'll discuss how we can use scripts to
generate expectations about discourses and
stories that help us make sense of the world around us. Finally, we'll
talk about the hierarchical nature of scripts. I think you'll enjoy this lesson.